dans l'histoire de la suède y en a une
qui est exceptionnel parce que c'est la
fois une chute est à la fois un énorme
moment de solitude rappelez-vous de
shy'm chanteuse allez dans votre centre
est là pour celui qui doit théoriquement
comme dans les grands conseils à
l'attraper sauf que la ville devant
stars font ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il faut faire c'est vraiment con al
assad et bien con parce que oui
qu'est-ce que mais se remette de sa
psychologiquement a ouais franchement
déjà se dire que les gens viendraient
vous aime pas beaucoup vous laisse
tomber les vraies raisons
alors écoutez ici de l'info de la bien
sûr en fait ces quelques jours après
c'est en 2015 après les attentats du
bataclan là donc les gens là oui on
conserve donc la salle est un peu moins
vers les publics
elle a l'habitude de le faire mais
d'habitude elle prévient le public pour
qu'il soit là un peu surexcités elle a
pas prévenus ouais et donc à l'excès on
regarde bien avant qu'elle arrive au
bord de la seine en fait elles vrille un
peu comme ça moi je pense qu'elle a pas
eu le temps de faire son impulsion
aussi d'aller elle fait pas le jeu
tourne comme ça l'histoire maman tu te
jettes et après tu te fais comme ça
voilà alors j'ai des pulsions c'est
génial si nous avons un budget illimité
on le voit ah oui mais le voir alors on
va faire une ronde à refaire la séquence
de shine vous allez monter sur scène mon
dieu et enfin ceux qui veulent
évidemment mais c'est qu'ils ont pas de
preuve deux ans tout ça aulas façon ça y
est on va décider et votez pour voir
qu'il est le meilleur chef génie
rapide mais je sens oui médical pour
vous dépassez pas longtemps et ce ne
sont neuf à maximaliser
[Applaudissements]
alors on va mettre des mots là vous êtes
prêts non on la met des protections oui
je les ai déjà dit alors on va commencer
on va on va commencer
on a commencé à insulter ni déjà on est
à peu près sûr d'avoir une si grosse
bêtise et pour le commission
[Applaudissements]
à
génie
[Applaudissements]
la malaisie ont pris cours il est calme
maintenant dépassé
alès
[Applaudissements]
non non non non
allez
soit
ok
[Applaudissements]
la sava manière illégale
daniel lamarre et bien voilà ça va
vraiment l'amour
[Applaudissements]
sa passat est question je dirais même
qu'on fait rien pour qu'elle fasse
quelque chose